This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Revolved on it. You go to the store for a pair of socks and come out with a mega pack of soda. You go out to get shampoo and come back with a fancy razor. It's hard to stick to what's on your list. I challenge you to go to IKEA and leave with only the thing for which you game. Just try to buy a lamp without buying a cutting board. It can't be done. You absolutely knew this, but retail spaces are designed to do this to you. Producer Avery Truffleman. The store is trying to look so beautiful, so welcoming, the item so enticingly displayed in such vast quantity that you cannot help but be drawn in, and then drawn towards something
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。关于它，我们来聊聊。你去商店买双袜子，结果却带回了一大包苏打水。你出门去买洗发水，回来时却带了一把昂贵的剃须刀。坚持只买清单上的东西很难。我向你挑战，去宜家，只买你原本打算买的东西。试着买一盏灯而不买一块砧板。这根本做不到。你绝对知道这一点，但零售空间的设计就是为了让你这样做。制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。商店试图看起来如此美丽、如此受欢迎，商品以如此巨大的数量诱人地展示出来，让你不由自主地被吸引，然后被吸引向某样东西，
you don't need. This is the Grooan Effect. The Grooan Effect, or sometimes called the Grooan Transfer, is that moment when you walk into a store and the design of the store is so overwhelming and dazzling that you begin mindlessly consuming. The Grooan Effect is named after Victor Grooan. So who was Grooan? is named after Victor Grooan. So who was Grooan?
你根本不需要的东西。这就是“格鲁恩效应”。格鲁恩效应，有时也称为“格鲁恩转移”，就是当你走进一家商店，商店的设计让你感到如此不知所措和眼花缭乱，以至于你开始盲目消费的那一刻。格鲁恩效应是以维克多·格鲁恩的名字命名的。那么格鲁恩是谁？是以维克多·格鲁恩的名字命名的。那么格鲁恩是谁？
He's a complicated, complex, contradictory guy. Jeff Hardwick wrote the biography of Victor Grooan, who was born Victor Grooanbaum. Born in Vienna in 1904, and he is Jewish in Vienna, leaves in 38. Good call, Grooanbaum. And makes his way eventually to New York City. Once in New York, Grun made a name for himself designing shops
他是一个复杂、矛盾的人。杰夫·哈德威克撰写了维克多·格鲁恩的传记，他原名维克多·格鲁恩鲍姆。1904年出生于维也纳，他是维也纳的犹太人，1938年离开。好决定，格鲁恩鲍姆。最终他来到了纽约市。到了纽约后，格鲁恩因设计商店而闻名，
and retail spaces. And this was a particular challenge during the lean years of the late 30s. People had no money. They just wouldn't go into shops at all. But Grun figured out how to lure people inside, basically by using amazingly appealing window displays.
和零售空间。在30年代末的困难时期，这尤其具有挑战性。人们没钱。他们根本就不去商店。但格鲁恩想出了如何通过使用极其吸引人的橱窗展示来诱导人们进入商店的方法。
You would go into these window display areas, look at jewelry or handbags or chocolates, and then you'd be tempted and lured into the store. I mean, that's the Groen effect. Groen argued that good design equaled good profits. And he quates those as one to one. If you do more, people are going to stay there longer and spend more money. Grue and started making store fronts all over the country.
你会走进这些橱窗展示区，看看珠宝、手提包或巧克力，然后你就会被诱惑并被吸引进商店。我的意思是，这就是格鲁恩效应。格鲁恩认为好的设计等于好的利润。他将两者等同起来。如果你做得更多，人们就会在那里停留更久，花更多的钱。格鲁恩开始在全国各地制作店面。
And he moved from New York to Los Angeles in 1941. Grue and was from the beautiful city of Vienna, which is lined with shops and greenery and places to gather. He saw how most Americans were just riding around in their cars all the time, cut off from the city and from each other. And he knew this problem was even worse in the suburbs. The suburbs lacked what sociologist Ray Oldenburg calls third places. Think of home as your primary place, work as your second place, and that third place
1941年，他从纽约搬到了洛杉矶。格鲁恩来自美丽的维也纳，那里商店林立，绿树成荫，是人们聚集的地方。他看到大多数美国人总是开着车到处跑，与城市和彼此隔绝。他知道这个问题在郊区更为严重。郊区缺乏社会学家雷·奥尔登堡所说的“第三空间”。把家当作你的第一空间，工作当作你的第二空间，而那个第三空间，
is where you go to build community to hang out, to simply feel connected. Groen wanted to give the American suburbs that third place. The image of living in closer communication with other people, the image of having the possibility from walk to one place to another. That's archival footage of Groen from the University of Wyoming. The image of participating in events outside of your own little house has become a desirable factor. Victor Groen imagined designing an environment full of greenery and shops, an indoor plaza, a modern forum, an island of connection in the middle of the sprawl,
就是你去建立社区、闲逛、简单地感到联系的地方。格鲁恩想给美国郊区提供那个第三空间。那种与他人更亲密交流的生活形象，那种可以从一个地方走到另一个地方的可能性。那是怀俄明大学关于格鲁恩的档案片段。参与自己小房子以外的活动这一形象已成为一个令人向往的因素。维克多·格鲁恩设想设计一个充满绿色植物和商店的环境，一个室内广场，一个现代论坛，在城市扩张的中间建立一个连接的岛屿，
one that would only be accessible to pedestrians. Because, oh man, Victor Groen hated cars. He ran and raves against cars continually. One technology event has swamped us. That is the advent of the rubber wheeled vehicle, the private cars, the trucks, the trailer, as means of mass transportation. And their threat to human life and hence is just as great as that of the exposed sewer. It's hard to understand them with the tape hiss in the accent, but what Groen is saying
一个只有行人才能进入的地方。因为，天哪，维克多·格鲁恩讨厌汽车。他不断地抨击汽车。一种技术事件淹没了我们。那就是橡胶轮车辆、私家车、卡车、拖车的出现，作为大众运输工具。它们对人类生命和健康的威胁，就像暴露的下水道一样大。在磁带的嘶嘶声和口音中很难理解他们，但格鲁恩所说的是，
there is. The threat of cars to human life and health is as great as the exposed sewer. So Groen's objective was to get people to park their cars far away from these third places and walk and stroll within them. As Groen saw it, his structure would be an architectural panacea. It would remedy environmental, commercial, and sociological problems with the creation of a single building. And so Gruen presented his solution for America, the shopping mall. Gruen actually wanted the shopping mall to be more than just shops. He wants them to be mixed use. He wants apartments and offices or medical centers
汽车对人类生命和健康的威胁就像暴露的下水道一样大。所以格鲁恩的目标是让人们把车停在离这些第三空间很远的地方，然后在里面散步和闲逛。在格鲁恩看来，他的结构将是一种建筑上的万灵药。它将通过创造单一的建筑来解决环境、商业和社会学问题。于是，格鲁恩为美国提出了他的解决方案：购物中心。格鲁恩实际上希望购物中心不仅仅是商店。他希望它们是混合用途的。他希望有公寓、办公室或医疗中心，
attached to the shopping center. He makes cases to have childcare facilities, libraries, bombshellters, a whole range of different functions. And Groen dreamed and wrote about being closed shopping center way before he ever built one. Until he finally lands a commission for the very first indoor climate controlled shopping center. In Adina, Minnesota, a place not known for its welcoming climate. Southdale represents an entirely new and dramatic concept in retail merchandise. Southdale Center opened in 1956,
附属于购物中心。他主张设立托儿设施、图书馆、防空洞，以及各种不同的功能。格鲁恩在建造第一个封闭式购物中心之前，就梦想并写下了关于封闭式购物中心的事情。直到他最终获得了第一个室内气候控制购物中心的委托。在明尼苏达州的伊迪纳，一个以气候不宜人而闻名的地方。南谷代表了零售商品中一个全新的、戏剧性的概念。南谷中心于1956年开业，
and it was the mother of all shopping malls. Seriously, ruined subsequent malls were all mostly based off this original adina design. When he's doing the first enclosed shopping mall, Southdale, and in a dinominic soda, but grew in really emphasizes and what the media ends up celebrating is this massive center court. This court has enclosed in skylighter,
它是所有购物中心之母。说真的，随后的购物中心大多基于这个最初的伊迪纳设计。当他做第一个封闭式购物中心，即明尼苏达州伊迪纳的南谷时，格鲁恩真正强调的，也是媒体最终庆祝的是这个巨大的中心庭院。这个庭院有天窗封闭，
so that not only the stores, but the shopping sidewalks. In fact, the whole area in front of the stores is air conditioned and temperature controlled, a year-round climate of 72 degrees. For Gruin, he's creating a town square. Southdale Center wasn't quite mixed use, like Groen imagined. People didn't live in it, and something like a daycare center or a post office couldn't afford that rent. But Southdale did have local shops of all kinds, and plenty of shoppers. Southdale, tomorrow's main street, today.
这样不仅商店，连购物人行道，事实上，商店前的整个区域都有空调和温度控制，全年气候保持在72华氏度。对格鲁恩来说，他正在创造一个城镇广场。南谷中心并不完全是格鲁恩设想的那种混合用途。人们不住在里面，像日托中心或邮局这样的地方也负担不起那里的租金。但南谷确实有各种各样的当地商店，还有大量的购物者。南谷，明天的商业街，今天就实现。
But from the outside, Southdale Center is not much to look at. I mean, it looks like a mall. It's a ominous, amorphous boxy shape. In designing these shopping malls, Grewin ended his razzle dazzle storefronts and window displays. Southdale hardly has exterior windows at all. He moves away from the original concept that in some ways they're going to attract by being ostentatious.
但从外面看，南谷中心没什么看头。我的意思是，它看起来像个商场。它是一个不祥的、无定形的盒子形状。在设计这些购物中心时，格鲁恩结束了他那令人眼花缭乱的店面和橱窗展示。南谷几乎没有外部窗户。他放弃了最初的理念，即在某种程度上，它们会通过炫耀来吸引人。
The drawn now is what's inside them all. In Grooons mind, it should have pretty much a blank facade, no signage on it, and then you enter that space and then you walk into the shopping center and that's that sort of transformational grue and transfer moment. Molls are designed as these sort of suburban pilgrimage sites, which of course you have to drive to. It's a commitment.
现在的吸引力在于商场内部。在格鲁恩看来，它应该有一个相当空白的外立面，上面没有标牌，然后你进入那个空间，然后你走进购物中心，这就是那种变革性的“格鲁恩转移”时刻。商场被设计成这些郊区的朝圣地，当然你必须开车去。这是一种承诺。
You're driving 20-30 minutes, you're parking, you're getting out of your car, you're walking in. Grue and knew that Americans love to drive. So the mall was as compromised. You had to walk and stroll once you were inside, but the customers could drive over. So he just hates the automobile, but he never will acknowledge that he's
你要开车20-30分钟，停车，下车，走进去。格鲁恩知道美国人喜欢开车。所以商场是一个妥协。你一旦进去就必须步行和闲逛，但顾客可以开车过来。所以他只是讨厌汽车，但他永远不会承认他正在，
creating these shopping centers, which are largely only accessible through cars. Ruin was right. Americans loved driving to his malls. He got commissions for them all over the country. But over time, Gruin sees that interacting these malls, these tiny suburban cities, he's helping to drain the real cities.
创造这些主要只能通过汽车进入的购物中心。格鲁恩是对的。美国人喜欢开车去他的商场。他在全国各地都接到了委托。但随着时间的推移，格鲁恩看到，通过这些商场，这些微小的郊区城市，他正在帮助掏空真正的城市。
And so for a while, Gruin shifts his focus to urban planning. We want to rescue our cities, which because we haven't neglected our threatening to go to pieces. And so Groen ends up being involved in urban renewal projects, where he draws directly on some of the lessons learned in his suburban shopping malls and proposes bringing them back downtown. Municipalities hire gruin and associates to make their downtowns more like malls. Gruin turns city centers into pedestrian-only spaces, full of public art and greenery and lined with shops.
所以有一段时间，格鲁恩将重心转移到了城市规划上。我们想拯救我们的城市，因为我们忽视了它们，它们正面临崩溃。于是格鲁恩最终参与了城市更新项目，他直接借鉴了他在郊区购物中心学到的一些经验，并提议将它们带回市中心。市政当局聘请格鲁恩及其合伙人使他们的市中心更像商场。格鲁恩将城市中心变成了仅限行人的空间，充满了公共艺术和绿色植物，并排满了商店。
He made plans for Boulder, Fresno, Fort Worth, Kalamazoo. Actually, his plan for Kalamazoo became the first outdoor pedestrian shopping mall in the US. He even had a concept to turn Fifth Avenue into a pedestrian mall. He gets Manhattan to close down Fifth Avenue for a couple weeks as a test. But a city's downtown is not a mall. It's not so easily quote unquote fixed, not so perfectly designed and controlled. Cities weren't going to become the pleasant sterile shopping environments
他为博尔德、弗雷斯诺、沃思堡、卡拉马祖制定了计划。事实上，他为卡拉马祖制定的计划成为了美国第一个户外步行购物中心。他甚至有一个将第五大道变成步行街的概念。他让曼哈顿关闭了第五大道几周作为测试。但城市的市中心不是商场。它不容易被“修复”，也不是那么完美地设计和控制。城市不会变成那种令人愉快的、无菌的购物环境，
that Groen wanted them to be. After the riots of the 60s, he is shocked and sort of taken a back by those and was very much unprepared for them. And I think that may have been somewhat of his reason for the retreat to Vienna. In 1968, Groen moved from Los Angeles back to Vienna. Back to the Greenery and Plazas. He had been trying to imitate. But he could not escape his own creation. There's a shopping mall that's being built on the edge of Vienna. And he points to that as how that shopping mall is destroying downtown Vienna.
格鲁恩希望它们成为那样。60年代的骚乱之后，他感到震惊，并被这些事情弄得措手不及，对它们非常没有准备。我认为这可能是他退回维也纳的部分原因。1968年，格鲁恩从洛杉矶搬回了维也纳。回到了他一直试图模仿的绿色植物和广场。但他无法逃避自己的创造。在维也纳边缘正在建造一个购物中心。他指出，那个购物中心是如何摧毁维也纳市中心的。
In Groen's mind, Vienna was already perfectly planned. It didn't need a mall like the broken American suburbs did. As he saw it, his original vision had been completely skewed. After being in Vienna about 10 years, he gives a speech and writes a paper where he says, I refuse to pay alimoni for these bastard developments. Victor Groen, the mall maker, became the foremost mall critic. And meanwhile, America's love affair with malls continued. Did you want to press the mall?
在格鲁恩看来，维也纳已经规划得很完美了。它不需要像破碎的美国郊区那样需要一个商场。在他看来，他最初的愿景已经被完全扭曲了。在维也纳待了大约10年后，他发表了一次演讲并写了一篇论文，他说：“我拒绝为这些混蛋开发项目支付赡养费。”商场制造者维克多·格鲁恩成为了最重要的商场批评家。与此同时，美国对商场的迷恋仍在继续。你想去商场吗？
It's a pretty girl like you doing sitting alone in the middle of this money you make to consumerism. I know I remember in my own experience growing up in New Jersey when the first mall opened anywhere near me when I was in high school. This is Ellen Dunham Jones. She's a professor of architecture and urban design at Georgia Tech. It was cool to go to the mall, but I mean literally it was air conditioned. My home wasn't air conditioned, my school wasn't air conditioned.
像你这样漂亮的女孩独自坐在这堆你制造的消费主义金钱中。我知道，我记得我自己在新泽西州长大的经历，当时我上高中时，离我最近的地方开了第一家商场。这是艾伦·邓纳姆·琼斯。她是佐治亚理工学院建筑与城市设计教授。去商场很酷，但我的意思是，它确实有空调。我的家没有空调，我的学校也没有空调。
Today, most of us are spending our days and our nights in completely thermally controlled environments. A lot of us are craving being able to be outdoors. In recent decades, our tastes have veered away from climate controlled environments and away from climate-controlled environments and away from the indoor mall. Mall construction actually peaked in 1990. It's been declining ever since, and by 2006, is really the last brand new kind of standard
今天，我们大多数人都在完全热控制的环境中度过白天和黑夜。我们很多人都渴望能够待在户外。近几十年来，我们的品味已经转向远离气候控制环境，远离室内商场。商场建设实际上在1990年达到顶峰。从那以后一直在下降，到2006年，这确实是最后一种全新的标准，
conventional mall that's been built in the U.S. And a new product has entered the scene, a kind of shopping center that the ICSC, the International Council of Shopping Centers, calls a Lifestyle Center. Lifestyle centers started appearing in the 90s and they tend to be open air, so you don't have that roof anymore. But you have a lot of boutiques and a lot more restaurants. Lifestyle centers are malls disguised as main streets. And even though they're full of chain stores, lifestyle centers are sunny and walkable and bustling,
在美国建造的传统商场。一个新的产品进入了现场，一种国际购物中心理事会（ICSC）称之为“生活方式中心”的购物中心。生活方式中心在90年代开始出现，它们往往是露天的，所以你不再有那个屋顶了。但你有很多精品店和更多的餐馆。生活方式中心是伪装成商业街的商场。即使它们挤满了连锁店，生活方式中心也是阳光明媚、适合步行且熙熙攘攘的，
and kind of what Victor grew and imagined. And some of the old-style indoor shopping malls are being repurposed. Several of them are being retrofitted into Hispanic community centers. Like in Plaza Fiesta outside of Atlanta. A lot of the stores have been cut up into much smaller mom and pop, small shops, selling Western wear, selling considerate dresses. Plaza Fiesta also has a steady events calendar of performances.
有点像维克多·格鲁恩设想的那样。一些旧式的室内购物中心正在被重新利用。其中一些被改造成了西班牙裔社区中心。就像亚特兰大郊外的“广场嘉年华”。许多商店被分割成更小的夫妻店，小商店，出售西部服装，出售体面的连衣裙。“广场嘉年华”还有一个稳定的表演活动日历。
In this too was kind of what grew and imagined. These sort of community malls are truly places to gather and spend money in the shell of the failed design. Most people architectural historians especially, they grew and was a horrible architect. And you know, I can see where they're coming from. I mean, his exteriors of his building are uniformly boring. But for Grooen, that wasn't the point. It was the interiors that were really the point.
这也是格鲁恩所设想的。这些社区商场确实是聚集和消费的地方，在失败设计的壳子里。大多数人，特别是建筑历史学家，认为格鲁恩是一个糟糕的建筑师。你知道，我能理解他们的想法。我的意思是，他建筑的外观千篇一律，很无聊。但对格鲁恩来说，重点不在于此。室内才是真正的重点。
Those fountains, the cheesy statues, the elevator music piped in through all those speakers. Those are all part of the groan effect, and they helped turn shopping malls into spaces where we felt comfortable staying and spending time and money. A lot of the original indoor malls are abandoned now. Seriously, like some of them are growing weeds inside. There's a website that's become sort of a graveyard of deadmalls called deadmalls.com. Users can log on and submit stories of the deadmalls in their towns.
那些喷泉、俗气的雕像、通过所有扬声器播放的电梯音乐。这些都是格鲁恩效应的一部分，它们帮助将购物中心变成了我们感到舒适、停留并花费时间和金钱的空间。许多最初的室内商场现在都被废弃了。说真的，有些里面甚至长出了杂草。有一个网站已经成为死商场的墓地，叫做deadmalls.com。用户可以登录并提交他们城镇中死商场的故事。
There are around 450 malls listed there, submitted as sort of oral histories. In particular, what's interesting, I think, about deadmalls.com is how nostalgic a lot of this is, and it does make sense. I mean, in so many suburban communities, the mall became the de facto town center. It was really the center of social life other than the school.
那里列出了大约450个商场，作为口述历史提交。我认为，关于deadmalls.com特别有趣的是，其中有多少怀旧情绪，这确实有道理。我的意思是，在这么多郊区社区，商场成了事实上的城镇中心。除了学校之外，它确实是社交生活的中心。
I would be very sad if all of Victor Groen's malls were demolished. We should certainly work to preserve at least one. The most famous mall in Minnesota may be the mall of America. With its roller coaster, it's zipline, it's aquarium and water park. But the most architecturally significant mall, its grandfather, is the one that's just a 12-minute drive away in a diner. Jeff Hardwick's book is called Mallmaker, Victor Groen architect of an American Dream. An Ellen Dunham Jones book is called Retro Fitting Suburban, special thanks to Claire Dordy for research help.
如果维克多·格鲁恩所有的商场都被拆除，我会非常难过。我们当然应该努力至少保留一个。明尼苏达州最著名的商场可能是美国商场。有它的过山车、滑索、水族馆和水上乐园。但建筑上最重要的商场，它的祖父，是那个在伊迪纳开车只需12分钟的地方。杰夫·哈德威克的书叫《商场制造者：维克多·格鲁恩，美国梦的建筑师》。艾伦·邓纳姆·琼斯的书叫《郊区改造》，特别感谢克莱尔·多迪提供的研究帮助。
99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Truffleman with Katie Mingle Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arksign, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown, mall-free, but lifestyle center rich Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, you can follow my international travels on Twitter, at Roman Mars, we're on Tumblr, Spotify and Instagram too. But over 160 episodes of 99% Invisible are waiting for you at 99pi.org. Radio Tepi. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本周的《99%隐形》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的、市中心的、没有商场但生活方式中心丰富的加利福尼亚州奥克兰的Arksign建筑和室内设计公司办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞该节目，你可以在Twitter上关注我的国际旅行，账号是Roman Mars，我们也在Tumblr、Spotify和Instagram上。超过160集的《99%隐形》在99pi.org等着你。Radio Tepi。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。